We've talked about Onion Routing and TOR, and
now i'd like to address the prickly subject of
hidden services, right? AKA the "dark web".
So Max has done a good video on the Dark Web,
and so you should definitely watch that one first,
so you know what it is. But it's quite a controversial topic,
because a lot of what happens on the Dark Web
is illegal, right? There's no two ways about it, that is true.
Some of it isn't, right, and a lot of what happens on TOR
in general--in fact the majority of what happens on TOR
in general, you know high Into the 90%
and that, and above--is perfectly fine, right?
it's just anonymous users browsing the web,
doing regular things but the TOR Hidden Services
are ones that the debate is about because
they're the ones where you sort of say
'well, look, is it worth this bit of encryption?
Is it worth, you know, all the criminality that's on there and so on?'
So here's my Cloud--my TOR Cloud
and in essence, we've got lots of people going into
the network. lots of encrypted layers and things
happening, bouncing around, and then people
coming out of the network to servers, right?
Now the issue, from a security standpoint
Is what happens if There's someone Sniffing?
Here and
someone's Sniffing here
and They Can Correlate Traffic between the in and The out
and Work out what it is that I am Doing
Specifically Right then the whole Report the whole Point of Tor Which is Anonymization?
Has been defeated, Right? We already have encryption, so that isn't the point of talk,
that's just how, They do the anonymous communication
so the Dark web. or a hidden service to use the Proper Term, is
in Essence Where This server Moves inside this Cloud right so now We have a hidden service Running Inside this Cloud and
There is no B that's the Idea right so it Makes it very very difficult to find so there is Now a circuit that goes
Somewhere Between A
Around the Place
To this Hidden Service
and at no point has that left the network so there's no traffic correlation that can be done, Right?
All of these are just TOR  sale messages that all look exacly the same.
Now, the way that TOR does this Is very very clever.
Euh, and I Look I will look into a little bit of detail on the protocol that it uses
But It's managed to form a
protocol where neither I nor the server
know who each other are, but we can still have a conversation which Is kind of nifty?
Okay
So then, let's start again with Onion routing
So, Onion routing is a protocol that could theoretically be implemented elsewhere.
There are other Mixing networks and things and other anonymization networks
But Hidden Services Is put predominately in the domain of TOR.
And TOR got the most users and the most nodes and it's the biggest and is in the News the most.
Let's Draw a little bit of a Network again, so
I shouldn't Have Drawn These Boxes Like This Because Now it takes me ages
So here's my server
Here's my Client and these
I'm Just going to Drawn with Boxes Because otherwise it's going to take far too long
These are Onion routers, so remember in normal Onion routing
The Client will Produce some
[Circuits] [or] some Hops and then they will Just Talk to the server but A server will be out on the normal Web Doing normal
Server Things
and won't be Anonymous what Hidden Services do Is
Anonymize This Server so they Allow Both the Server and The Client to talk to each other Despite the fact that
No One Knows who each other is Which Is quite Impressive
[Now] of Course if You then use [that] service Connection to Log in You're going to know you are but You get the idea
The Server Has To lay some Groundwork Down before A client Connects use a hidden Service Right so there's protocols in the Tor
Specification for doing This but [what] the server will do when they come online Is they will pick Three Onion Routers at Random and
Name Them as Introduction Points so let's Pick Them at Random now These are just normal Onion Routers They're very Likely to be Just doing
Regular
Normal Routing Tasks Like Circuits Through other Clients Into Servers and Things Some of These might be Exit Nodes
Entry Nodes and so on but As far as I know all Onion Routers Can, also act as
Introduction Points it's not A big Job [I] didn't Require A Huge Amount of Bandwidth the server will Make Connections
Circuits
to These introduction Points They've Either Full on tour Circuits with Three hops in Between Them the idea being That These introduction Points Know They're
Going to be introducing People to this server
But they don't know who it Is
Why it's Already the server is Hiding behind A layer of Anonymity here it will send Them a message to say I'd like you to
Act As an Introduction Point and Then
It will Create something Called A server Hidden Service Descriptor which I was [write] Down here that will Include the service Public key for
Occasion Purposes But I won't dwell on that Particularly but
Also Crucially the ip Addresses [of] These introduction Points Here Now These are all public Anyway they will Publicly Listed
Now it will Publish This Descriptor to something Called a Distributed hash Table that is to [Say] all [of] the Routers on Tor
will Hold Some in Some Part of the Information [on] all of These hidden Services
And the idea Is that if I try and Look up a hidden Service
The [Roots] Are Responsible for it will Give Me Back the Descriptor by including the Addresses
[Over] The Introduction Points Now the key for this Hash table is the Onion Address
Right so the Onion dress that Everyone Knows about
Is actually derived from the public key [of] this Server and Is in Essence the key but Gets
These ips Out of the Distributed hash table the whole Point of this Is [that] the Onion Address isn't publicized on the Global Tor Network
You Just find it other Ways like on A net
On an Internet or your friend tells you or?
in an Email or something like this the [Waiver] [the] Distributed hash Table Is
Programmed The vast Majority of Nodes Won't know what the description Is for A given Key I?
Only want more Probably or couple so there's an Inherent Security here it doesn't until Recently it's
Also Made it Quite difficult to Work at how Many Hidden services There were so this Is all set up now the server sits There
And Waits for [Internet] [Connections] [Or] People to ask for A, web web file Now
and These Onion Routers These ips the
Introduction Points Just sit There Being in Being normal Routed and Waiting here me I want to connect to this Hidden Service and Someone gave
Me the Onion Address so that's Really, what I need so what I do is I?
Request The descriptor off the hash Table and it gives it back that has the Three ip
And i pick one At random right let's Say This Top
One here what I'm going to do in Essence The Short Version
Is i'm going to ask this ip to Introduce me to a server and Then
We're Going to meet in The Middle at someone [debut] Point that's the idea so let's Work out How it Works
I'Ve Sort of run out of colors so i'm going to go?
Over the Orange Pen Here it's A bit bright I choose A
Rendezvous Point at Random and I create A [tour] Circuit to that Rendezvous Point Remember that Essentially all of These Arrows are the full
Connections This One has Two Hops on it not Three Because the Rendezvous Point is a third Hop
So it Goes on like this Now I send a message to the one 7-Point Saying I'd like you to Introduce me [to] the server
By This Introduction Point and I want you to send it the word
Cookie Right now that Could Be Any string [it's] not Important [the] point Is sort of like a One-Time Password Kind of Thing to verify
but no
One Else has got Involved in This Conversation the Rendezvous Point Creates a circuit to this IP and sends it the Word Cookie it
Also sends its Own Address Because of Course this, doesn't know it because the Circuit and We [need] to be at a rendezvous Here
so this ip
Forwards The Cookie On to the Server and At this Point the Server Can Either Accept it and Decide to try and Make a Connection
Or do Nothing right so you Can Imagine a situation where Instead of A cookie Some kind of special Password
But you need to be able to connect to this Website and
The Server Just Does Nothing that's that's One Thing that Could happen right They Have an Authentication Token I think but at
This Point the Introduction Points Job is done There is no more
These Would be the serve Their Purpose all they do is Forward the Cookie [Onto] the server right
Bear in Mind, We don't know where it Is and
Eat the server Decides Whether it's going to connect
Let's Assume because Otherwise this will
Be a much Shorter Video that the server does want to talk said he to the Rendezvous Point so it creates
Another Circuit I don't know How Many 1 2 3 4 5 but at
[5] we've got [Six] Circuit right Across the Tor Network to the one David point Which is the cookie of The Wrong very Important Details
yes That Rendezvous Point Details will be
Well [it] be attached to the same message with the Cookie and yes Good Question now
The Server Sends The One They've Appoint A
Rendezvous Please Essentially Message [Weave] the Cookie in it and the Mod Labelled Point Looks at These Two cookies and Goes
Well I was requested of [One] They [blew] by this guy With this Cookie I've Received a Connection from some server
Also with the cookie They must be Talking About each other right that's the Idea it Could be doing Lots of on the Moves at
The Same Time With Different Cookies and it will then
Act as Just Another Hop on This Network and Connect These two up so this Comes over here like this and
This Comes Down Here and They Kind of get Bridged by this Rendezvous Point here Convened
On the Rendezvous Point [Acts] like A normal [Onion] mu 2 and Just decrypt Messages
Passes Them out the other Side like Always
so
for Anyone That's Sort of Lost count
There are at
Least six Hops here Right There Two intermediate Node on this Circuit then the Rendezvous Point in Three Intermediate Nodes on
This Circuit Right it's Just Part of the Protocol [that] There's only [Two] this Side that's Obviously going to be quite A lot slower than
Normal Talk These Could
Be all over the World like this it's going to Take quite a long Time
But There is no real Way of getting in on this Conversation
Right if You're Sniffing here or sniffing here all you're Seeing Is encrypted [tor] cells all of 512 bytes Long Jumping Around this Place
She's got, no Idea what any of Them are right very very difficult to track that's why, it's so difficult to find
Hidden Services okay Because They're Hidden yeah kind of the Point they, wouldn't Have Couldn't They?
[did] Something Else no they did in Term
They Didn't Name it Incorrectly to Say
Sometimes Were Vulnerabilities Found in The Protocol right or Compromised knows Which Allow Hidden Services to be Found this happened for example Silk Road -
But that's not [That] Common right and There's the bigger the Network Gets The more beautiful no Combinations are The heart of That Process Gets
Now as an Aside
Some Servers don't need Anonymity and this Many hops is too slow [all] right so they want to protect Their Clients but
They don't Care About but if People know who they are Facebook for example so Facebook Work
Foot-Tall Recently to Introduce Something Called Single Onion in That case the only Difference is the bit Server
Doesn't bother With These Three hops it just goes straight to the Rendezvous Point
Now That Obviously [Forgoes]
Servers Anonymity Because [The] One Living Point knows what it Is but it Takes a puppy
We know [Whether] servers are I think right so they don't mind about that Their Business Is protecting Their Customers
They don't Care but We know Where Their servers are so that's an Alternative and you it's quite A lot faster because you've Removed Three
Possibly Global Hops from There What Benefit Is [that] Facebook - you know some of Just using A normal tor
Connection Facebook There's a small Chance if You're using a normal tor Connection that some will be Sniffing Here and Sniffing Here and do Traffic
Correlation and Work out what's going on?
Right [There's] no chance About happening when it's a hidden server it Never leaves the Tor Network that's the thing if you Imagine that Cloud
You're Talking to Facebook Entirely Inside That Cloud very Hard to get in but on the other Hand
Facebook Server Location is Actually Known because if you
Were Operating the Rendezvous Point and Facebook said we'd like to connect back to the Client you'd immediately know that Because it's [Facebook's] Server so
it's like a Halfway Compromise
And i think a fairly reasonable Compromise so it's Facebook Putting one Foot, Inside the Cloud yeah yeah one Foot
Inside did to Talk Loud
With messages Encrypted Once With K3 it's encrypted Another Time with K2 and
When it's encrypted a final Time
With K1 Now Let's Think about what that means it Means that only This Routes are Here